j'incite pas les commerçants à faire
comme moi je vous dis juste moi je veux
bien assumer et j'assumais
responsabilités j'assume les
conséquences de mon geste je reconnais
que parfois ça m'ennuie de voir toute
cette exposition de ces individus même
si c'est moi qui les provoqué je pensais
pas que ce serait autant relayé je
pensais par recevoir autant de centaines
de messages de clients ou commerçants
qui m'ont dit mais vous avez eu 1000
fois raison nous on l'a jamais fait vous
avez eu raison de le faire les
conséquences pour eux c'est quoi
les conséquences pour moi oui les
conséquences pour eux c'est rien mais
encore une fois moi je suis un petit
commerçant à Amiens qui est une ville
remarquable d'ailleurs il y a pas plus
de vol et de délinquance à Amiens
qu'ailleurs mais il faut le faire réagir
là haut et leur dire donner les moyens à
la police on a la vidéo surveillance à
Amiens donnant les moyens aujourd'hui
les commerçants ils portent puisque
toute façon mais bien sûr d'aboutira pas
vous passez des heures et des heures à
porter plainte je connais les
commerçants qui toutes les semaines vont
porter plainte on leur dites quoi ces
gens-là et ben c'est ce qu'il faut faire
bah il faut payer quelqu'un qui fait que
ça